- [Voiceover] Hello grammarians.
So today we're gonna talk
about third and final function
of the colon.
So this final function of the
colon is that it can be used
as a separator.
So it might sound like we're talking about
the comma again, right?
The comma separates
elements of a sentence.
But the colon does it in
kind of a different way.
So, let's look at some examples.
So one common use of
the colon as a separator
is in titles.
So you can have two separate
parts of the title, or like
a title and a subtitle
for a book or a movie
or a TV show.
And there will be a colon in between them.
We can have something like
Bear Man: Adventures in Alaska.
Another common use of the
colon as a separator is in
citations from a book or a poem,
and pretty often the Bible.
For example, we can use
it to separate the number
of a Bible chapter from
the number of the verse.
If we want to reference First
Corinthians, Chapter 13,
Verse four, we can write it like
One Corinthians 13
colon four.
Finally, we can use the
colon to separate the hour
from the minutes in the time of day.
If I want to tell someone what time it is,
I can say it is now ten-oh-nine AM.
And between the ten, which
is the hour of the day,
and oh-nine, which is the
minutes, we put a colon.
So that's how the colon
works as a separator.
We can use it in titles,
citations, and times.
You can learn anything.
Paige out.